so The Last of Us seven is now out and
this episode's filled with a ton of
Easter eggs callbacks to the game and a
lot of things that flesh out Ellie's
backstory based on the Left Behind DLC
that saw us learning more about what
happened to her during the time that Joe
was at death's door in the game
originally after he fell off the horse
he had a massive section where he played
as her for about an hour and you had
absolutely no idea whether Joel was
alive or dead he was agonizing fighting
through the infected to discover what
happened but here we find that in the
opening that he's okay he did have a
weak weight but yeah it wasn't as tense
as that hour-long session now in The
Last of Us Part One remake was released
last year I was thinking that they might
add in the Left Behind chapter so it
happened in chronological order they
didn't know and sandman's the only show
I've seen come with DLC so they dropped
it in here where it should take place in
the story whether they do skip over a
big part of it dealing with Ellie
searching for supplies in the game the
story was split in half and we ended up
getting two scenarios set inside a mall
throughout the DLC you jump back and
forth between the two and in the first
you saw what we get in the mall with
Riley in the second section it was a
completely different location set in the
present where you followed Ellie as you
looked for supplies this took you to a
crashed military Chopper in the area and
he found that the mall was teeming with
infected after getting the supplies you
made your way back to Joel which is
where you had to protect him from
Hunters who were out for his blood now
we start off with a snowy abandoned
neighborhood which we learn is where
giolin Ali went to after them all Upon
returning home from hunting you saw that
Ellie had hitched up somewhere like this
and they really managed to recapture the
look of the location similar to The
Source material we find Joel in the
basement on a mattress and Ellie's been
doing DIY surgery in order to try and
heal him and now we can also catch an
empty tool rack and these have all been
taken and likely used for weapons it
reminded me of the kind of houses you'd
find in the game where everything had
been picked clean because I'd been
spamming the triangle button now Jill
tells her to go to Tommy and last week
he of course wanted him to take it his
worst fears come true and he's put her
in a lot of danger and is now holding
her back Joel is very much the kind of
person who would just ditch someone who
was in this position because in this
world it doesn't really allow for
hangers on as she puts the code on him I
think we see genuine love in his eyes
and he realizes this is more than what
he's had before but there's she even
said that he didn't really love her and
they were just together because they
were both good at surviving he very much
sees Ali as a second daughter though and
she views him as the father that she
never had now we sort of get a similar
pot device to Left Behind and as
something new happened in that we then
cut to the Past Ellie's about to step
out of the basement at this point and we
flash back to her in a federal training
camp yeah we can see that she has a
Walkman and this is something that she
also had in the comic as she runs
circuits we can hear her listening to
all in on by Pearl Jam they're quite an
important band in the franchise and the
song Future Days was a thing that
constantly popped up throughout at the
time of part 2's release it was a big
thing about how the song didn't actually
get released by the time the outbreak
happened however no Naughty Dog pointed
out that they'd done a live show where
they played it so the characters could
actually know the song honestly I don't
think people would have cared because it
is quite sad obsessing over this type of
stuff or that the outbreak was moved
forward 10 years for the show so that
song pops up here I'm gonna [__] kick
off I'm [__] furious this moment is
pretty much the academy in the comics
and it's clear they wanted to tie it
back to that often overlooked Last of Us
offshoot although in that we saw Ellie
with Riley Raz here she's already left
the bullies there capitalizing this and
one called Bethany rips her headphones
off and taunts her for having no one to
fight her battles it's clear Ellie
gravitates towards authority figures and
Riley is very much a prototype gel
protector figure we learn from Captain
kuang that she's been acting differently
the last couple of weeks since Riley
left and her friend departing is another
example of someone leaving her Ellie
never really got to know her mother she
was palmed off by Marlene Tess died and
Jill tried to get rid of her with Tommy
you can see why she told Sam she was
tired of being alone like Al Green and I
think it's really good writing to sell
the seeds of this in this flashback
moment it's clear everyone is ties to
the past they hold on to just like Ellie
does and we see that even Captain Kwong
has trouble letting go he has a faded
picture of his family on his desk and
I'm guessing he's died during the
initial outbreak now Ellie's being
thrown in the hole several times before
and instead of punishing her Quang wants
to give her some advice He suggests that
she aims to be an officer and
demonstrates this path by throwing down
his keys the first path is a cub and the
second being Keys is symbolic because
this will open up doors for her it also
added a really cool little Easter egg on
them too and we catch the Naughty Dog
logo on a keyring that Quang has now
this conversation in scene is very much
another side of fedra that we haven't
seen before in the game they are pretty
much always your enemies as are the
bandits that you encounter along the way
however the series has shown things from
their point of view because in the game
we will look to Joel and Ellie's
perspective really shows you all these
kinds of points of views and it allows
you to actually sympathize eyes with
them Huang believes that fedra is the
only thing holding the world together
and that if they go down the world will
fall apart in Kansas City we saw things
were like if Federer or house did and
the people there were carrying out
murders and just doing horrible things
Federer also helped to push the infected
in the ground there and Kathleen's need
for Revenge unleash this on her people
now in her room we catch some dinosaur
drawings and also a picture of some moon
cycles we'll go over what these four
shadows in the spoiler section but these
being Ellie's interests are very very
important we also get to know pun
intended book by Will Livingston and her
knife just slightly below it out of view
this is actually volume one or as we see
Riley busting out Volume 2 later on this
is a slight change up from the game as
in those they found it in the mall when
coming across A hermits Camp Riley then
read it as you made your way through or
as yeah she has it already oh I got
something else we also catch Ellie
reading a Savage Starlight comic which I
think is titled Negan trippy nugentrippy
anyway in our episode 5 video we talked
about how these were Collectibles that
you'd pick up in the game and the
negentropy issue was something that you
came across on your travels we see the
inside of it being a big action scene
involving a man and a woman bursting
their way into somewhere probably
reaching uh but I think this is very
much how Ellie views her and Joel and
the guy in the book even looks slightly
similar to how he does in the game
doesn't he well he well either way her
room is very empty since Riley left
although it's not too long until she
returns but we get another tour of her
room and see some tapes the top one by
aha foreshadow is a great moment in the
second game near the James one plays in
this episode later on I got you babe
it's a song we hear Riley and Ellie
dancing to at the end and this music was
also what they jammed away to in the
mall on Riley's fateful last night you
also see a poster for Mortal Kombat 2
and this makes a big return later on in
the episode during the third entry we
saw as Ali and Joel came across a
cabinet for it which in the game was a
fighter called the turning it started
character Angel knives but with the show
being a Warner Brothers property they
have the rights to use the Mortal Kombat
characters I think that the game
developers likely knew this was going to
be an Easter egg in advance and in the
recent Last of Us remake they actually
added an immortal Combat 2 poster Riley
then climbs in through the window and
she ends up sticking her hand over
Ellie's mouth this is slightly different
to the game as in that she pretended to
bite her is of course foreshadowed her
fate and let's play the scene side by
side so you can see what they kept and
also what they changed
thank you
[Music]
Riley
ow wow Riley owl
I landed on my hip what the hell
I thought I Was Bitten I know it was
kind of Awesome
hold me like that joke
okay I thought it would work better in
my mind loved it
you're not gonna kill me are you
I haven't seen you
and I don't even know how long 45 days
well
46 technically
so
what's it going
to know what I've been up to
all this time
I thought you were dead
are you okay I'm fine I just ran away
for a bit that's all here
look
no way where were you
I joined the Firefly oh [__] you
you're a firefly
you're a firefly Jesus
are we cool
I disappeared and you're mad
and I owe you an explanation
let's get out of here and I'll tell you
all about it we'll tell you everything
first you have to promise me something
it's almost morning and I have military
drills
you know where we learn how to kill
fireflies so yeah I'm not going anywhere
with you it's
great it's chewy I mean in a few hours I
have drills
fireflies
put some pants on and let's go
so there are some slight changes there
but lots of similarities too Riley is
now a firefly and huge shootout star out
of the map but picking up this sort of
Romeo and Juliet Vibes here with them
being on opposite sides now I'm actually
in the middle of moving house at the
moment and you might notice I've been
cleaning things out I've been cleaning
them out that's why we've teamed it with
MacBook to bring you clean my Mac x a
brand new program that you need to get
if your storage is filling up if you're
a Mac User then I'm sure you know that
Macs don't have a lot of storage and
it's very expensive to buy more Macs
store a lot of cash and if you delete
them manually you can accidentally
delete things that you need which can
cause a lot of trouble it's also very
difficult to delete apps and sometimes
when you move them to the trash the day
with them doesn't actually go and it
takes up a lot of storage on the ram
it's not great for multitasking it's
gonna cause a lot of issues and it'll
leave you Max slower than a heavy
spoilers upload after a night out hey
I'm not being a team we use a lot of
massive files for video editing
sometimes they can be like 20 gig big
which when you've got hundreds of them
on a project it can really start to take
up space on your Mac and just make
everything a lot more difficult than it
needs to be how about clean my Mac X
checks out how much unneeded junk you
have on your Mac and it completely
cleans it out this will improve your
speed and storage and generally you just
make things a lot easier why put this
additional load on your Mac with
unnecessary apps when you can just clean
it out in a second with clean my Mac X
it erases your files securely gets rid
of hibernation files and just keeps your
privacy online extremely safe it also
speaks a number of different languages
so whatever one you use clean my Mac X
has got you covered make sure you check
out the link in the description below go
and try it for free now and yeah get
things sorted out in the game as you're
cutting between timelines you join alien
Riley jumping into an abandoned
Apartment block which is way here trucks
outside
oh man
that was close huh however here we see
them very much moving through the street
as trucks travel through looking for
people breaking curfew eventually go
down into an Alleyway and then into this
which is when they bust out the Torches
Elise doesn't work and she has to hit it
and in the game from time to time you'd
have to shake the controller when your
light was going off now there's a point
in the game we learned how Riley became
a firefly which I'm gonna play with the
show version so you can see how things
slightly differ remember that Firefly
you bet installed his gun
yeah I remember him that's Trevor I saw
him walking down the street so I tailed
his hat one night you were in the hole
I got bored so I snuck out I follow him
into this alley and all these fireflies
Ambush me
they took me right to their Hideout to
Marlene I was on my way back being
stealthy like I am and this chick popped
out of nowhere chick like our age no
like 40. were you scared
terrified I thought this time she would
actually shoot me
but instead she just says what took you
so long whatever anyways old she said
she was impressed watching me sneak
around avoiding guards she was expecting
me
and she just made you a firefly
something like that and she asked what I
thought about fedra so I told her the
truth they're fascistic bags and they're
the ones that should be getting hanged
for their crimes that hole almost
killing me thing was a test
she wanted to know I was committed
oh
she's like all right if you want in
you're in
that's it I'm in the show the woman
she's talking about is clearly Marlene
who recruited her personally or as in
the game she was brought to her makes it
seem like Marlene's been keeping an eye
on Ellie for a long time and that she's
now as those around her too eventually
if she had someone on her side that was
close to Ellie Ellie would be warmer to
her and it also explains why the
fireflies didn't immediately kill Ellie
when she was bitten Moline has a close
attachment with Ellie and her plans to
keep her safe and knowing Riley might
have helped with that however it could
also be the reasoning why she shipped
Riley off as she didn't want her running
away with her friend who discovered
later on that Riley actually asked if
Ali could join her but Marlene said no
she just wanted to keep her in the QC
and potentially they may have moved
Riley for that reason now in the apollon
block they also find a guy who seemingly
overdosed on pills Ali and Jill of
course come from the same QC and it's
possible that Joel even sold him these
as they are similar to what we saw him
dealing in episode 1. it could be
teasing the danger that Joel has around
him and how his actions have a negative
effect on people now a body lying
against a wall like this is also somehow
very much foreshadows infected later on
most of those that had cordyceps ended
up with it taking over their body and
growing at their face and they'd
eventually hit a point where they knew
they were going to die if they didn't
become full-on clickers thus they'd head
to a wall lay down die and grow into it
and in the games they'd spread out
spores the other one in the mall isn't
dead he's very much following the same
pattern and the body against the wall
here at least to me sets that up it
collapses through the floor and they
take his booze with them and drink it on
the roof Ali pretends to love it and
this is a complete opposite of the
campfire scene in which he spat it
straight out he's trying to impress
Riley and we do see a different side to
her here now we learned that it's not
the first dead body Riley scene and that
she's witnessed her parents corpses most
of the kids taken in by fedra were
orphans and this allowed them to train
the kids to be soldiers if you have ties
to your family and stuff you're less
likely to be loyal to things like better
especially when they're oppressing the
very people you're connected with Ali
asks to see Riley's Gun and we then see
her obsessing over it this is something
she's done throughout the series and
Neil lure of power means a lot to her as
she's not really experienced the bad
side of it at this point they talk about
fedra and also the fireflies Riley sees
them as fascists whereas Ellie sees them
as holding everything together Riley
thinks the fireflies are gonna bring
freedom but we've already seen from
Kathleen the kind of thing it leads to
she ended a promising Fair trials that
people would live if they gave up others
and in the end this was shown to all
just be a lie fedra also do terrible
things too think what it boils down to
is that no matter what happens the worst
traits of humanity will always emerge in
some form or another no matter the side
well they're all good sights too and
obviously these sides have their appeals
as well in the end though whichever side
is in charge will oppress the other side
in some form and thus we get these
divisions that lead to others attempting
to seek power when they finally get it
they want to punish you the side who now
become the oppressed ones and the cycle
starts again Riley later brings up how
fedra have stopped people and in the
game when he got to Pittsburgh he found
graffiti talking about how the people
there were famished Ellie said it didn't
help that the fireflies bombed the
storage Depot which Riley sees as being
propaganda hit up any social media site
you're gonna see people talking about
the faults in the other political side
whilst dismissing their own I think
Ellie and Riley show we can find common
ground with stuff like this now Riley
says that the fireflies don't carry out
attacks when civilians are involved but
tell that to test and Robert now in the
game there was an extra Dimension to
this as there was an announcement that
said there hadn't been an affection for
30 days Riley said this was a lie and
that it was just covered up I kind of I
was hoping that this would appear in the
show as we of course saw Joel having to
burn lots of bodies in episode 1. this
scene does kind of mimic the game a bit
as your first run along rooftops before
coming alongside the more like what we
have here the pair then drop down to a
collapsed roof and they enter the
Liberty Gardens Mall this is the same as
what the location is called in the game
and they do rearrange things slightly
originally you saw the typhoon Blitz
poster which was a water pistol I used
against Riley during one of the pairs
final scenes together it was the game
across a 10 for a man named Winston who
we learned had been living in the mall
as a recluse as I mentioned earlier he
was who you got the pun bug from and you
learned that he died of old age in this
world that's a big thing as there's it's
very much survival of the fittest so
making it to that point really means a
lot and from here you went to the
Halloween shop and then you threw some
bricks at some car windows to see who
could smash the most the winner smashed
the like button as well and then from
here the characters turned the power on
and went on the Merry-Go-Round here
though they flipped the power on first
before they head into the mall so turns
out the whole city has power
they just flip the circuit breakers all
you gotta do is flip it back
so turns out when Fedrick connected that
block up to the grid this place got
connected too
not that they know at this point we get
a scene that's very reminiscent of the
game with Ellie opening a bit door into
the mall in which we see it all light up
we also have a play on the escalator
scene which pulls directly from that
whoa look at me
[Laughter]
this is the first Wonder on the day now
and from here we catch a poster for dawn
of the Wolf Part 2. like Curtis and
Viper two this was a fictional movie
within the last of us universe and
here's what they had to say about it in
the game
posters are every
where I saw this before the outbreak he
did
he totally get her by the end
nobody gets gutted it's a it's a dumb
Teen Movie who dragged you to see it
though
I don't know let's just stay focused all
right
I also loved the little back in five
minute sign and it shows just how much
people were caught off guard guy just
popped out for a poo and didn't end up
coming back everything happened really
quick but at least people had time to
loot Foot Locker and probably also get
loads of toilet paper we also get an
added a lingerie scene with Ellie trying
to Smart herself up after Riley makes a
joke about imagining her in it from here
we go to the Merry-Go-Round which pulls
directly from the PlayStation classic
it's probably the most memorable part of
Left Behind and in the game it's chewing
this that Riley gets out the pun book
symbolically merry-go-rounds are a sign
of innocence and simplicity that puts
people in a loop far removed from the
world around them illiteracy works that
are often used as sources of magic and
adventure and carousels like this are
commonplace at amusement parks as they
bring joy to lots of people this is just
the pair enjoying what for them as our
last night on earth before a major
change happens though Ali doesn't know
it Riley is well aware he's meant to be
going away and either way Ellie is about
to lose hair forever now similar to what
happens in the game the the ride breaks
down and it spoils the moment the
furnace cut short and it's very much
foreshadowing the journey that lies
ahead and we discovered that Riley was
about to turn 17 and that she'd been
assigned to sewage detail this is all
that Quang thought she was good for and
you can see why she ended up running
away Fred ran the duties assigned to
people were very much prisons themselves
and in this world people didn't really
have the freedom to do what they want no
one was lucky enough to just sit around
talking about movies all day and you can
see why people gravitate towards the
promise of freedom and Liberation now on
the merry-go-round in the game Riley
busts out the pun book but here they
kind of skip over it save it for later
and just go straight to the photo booth
the show being said 10 years earlier
does mean that they can't bring certain
things over and in the game it ended by
asking if you wanted to share your
photos to Facebook neither knew what
that was and instead he got printouts of
the photos before the whole thing shut
down in a nice fourth wall breaking
moment you could actually share the
photos you made and came to your own
Facebook and that was an awkward
conversation explaining to my dad why I
was posting pictures of young computer
generated girl
now in both the show and game we get the
little bunny mascot however the names
changed up because of the whole Facebook
thing the game has it being called
sharesnap or as the show is star shot
because they couldn't have posted it
online with it being set in 2003 yeah
Facebook wasn't around then and it's
genuinely one of my favorite Easter eggs
in the entire show and I love when they
put this much thought into it now from
here they go into the arcade we see
machines for Tetris Frogger attack from
Mars and Daytona USA this was about
driving across the country which may be
a link to Joel and Ellie doing it as as
two seats there also in the game Ellie
jumped in a Jack and Daxter machine and
naughty dog of course made that game
also worth pointing out that Ellie's
wearing the shirt that we saw her
wearing in episode 1 and this was also
the shirt that Young Nathan Drake wore
in Uncharted 3. anyway in the show Ellie
gets to play Mortal Kombat 2 whereas in
the game The Turning cabinet didn't
actually work instead Riley described
the game to Ellie she had her eyes
closed and he just imagined pulling off
the combos I'm guessing Naughty Dog
didn't have the resources to design The
Mechanics for a fighting game for what
amounted to about two minutes in the
game but here we catch them playing it
out they go to the Deadpool stage and a
Deadpool is when you bet on who's gonna
die put my entire house on Riley and now
move into Vegas baby
anyway Riley chooses my Lena and she
pulls off her fatality which Ali
described her as doing back in episode
three this is one character named Melina
who takes off her mask and she has
monster teeth and then she swallows you
whole and Barks out your bones now as
they're playing away we cut to one of
the infected who's been awakened by the
lights coming on and all the noise he's
located in a toy shop and this is very
much a symbol of Innocence which he ends
up destroying we see two dolls here and
this could be a reference to the two
mannequins and the clothes shop stand
which is where the attack happens in the
game yeah they just shrink it down so
that it happens in the Halloween store
rather than them going there I think the
change from mannequins to dolls again is
to hammer homeless creepy factor and
also the idea that this is Ellie's
childhood being destroyed as things
drastically change from this point
onwards she's no longer under the
production of Federer and is basically
made to flee the qzi with Joel now from
here Riley takes Ellie to Macho Nacho
this is another great Naughty Dog Easter
egg and in Uncharted Nate asked Elena if
she actually used to work there he came
across this in the morning left behind
as well and now they've brought across
to the show with it being where Riley
was camped out at the pun book comes out
and we hear the ones which also show up
in the game what did the frustrated
cannibal do frustrated cannibal threw up
his hands
[Music]
laid on me he threw up his hands what
did the triangle say to the circle oh
what did the triangle say to the circle
you're so pointless
oh in the back Ellie discovers that
Riley's been making explosives and that
she was actually posted here by the
fireflies these look identical to some
of the weapons you get in part two and
as Ellie goes over you can see that on
the top shelf there is a federal
container they likely we're going to put
this in a deliberate using Gorilla
Warfare to take them out Riley promises
Ali that they wouldn't be used on her
but there's absolutely no way that Riley
could guarantee that say Ellie did
become an officer then she would be the
kind of person they target and we see
how people are very much forced to go
against each other I like the game we
learned this as well last night in
Boston and it plays off the back of this
scene Ellie I'm leaving
they've asked me to leave
leave what
Boston
I'm supposed to join a group in another
city
they're sending me to a post in the
Atlantic cutesy
I argued with them to stay here
I asked if you could join
Joy so we could go together
but you know how Marlene is nothing's
easy with her everything's a test but
Marlene said no the [__] is Marley
Marlene is the lady that helped me it
doesn't matter
they're picking me up tomorrow
tonight's my last night in Boston
why did you bring me here
I wanted to see you
bring me here
because I wanted to see you
no why did you bring me here
I don't know
iqz is all is something we hear about in
the game when you're in Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh was a city that had
overthrown Federer and we discovered
that some of the remnants ended up
fleeing and going to Atlanta in
Halloween store we see a decoration
popping out of a grave and this is
similar to creature bursting out of the
coffin in the game counterpart Riley
gives her the pun book explaining how
she got it and she talks about the doubt
that she has going with them however
Riley says because Ali never had a
family she doesn't understand even with
the bad you still accept people and
later on when Joel becomes his surrogate
father she very much accepts all looking
bad things in him now he's being put
through the ringer and she goes through
how Riley left her gave her this amazing
night and is then leaving her again I
think Ellie gets so attached to people
that she's willing to let them walk all
over her to some extent and believe
their lies because it's easier than
losing them Riley says she's sure about
leaving and Ellie says that she'll miss
her which is when Riley gives her a
werewolf mask whilst Riley gets a clown
one the characters wore both these masks
along with a couple of others and Ellie
ended up doing her best role in the
werewolf one which was a really fun way
to start off the mall section
at the end of the DLC you went to a
clothes shop which is when you had a
water pistol fight using the typhoon
Blitz which he saw a sign for early on
after this Riley put the tape on and you
danced on top of the table like what we
get here it's side by side time and just
be aware that we've muted the music here
for copyright reasons a bit awkward but
that's YouTube
really
[Music]
really come here
what is it
okay what's wrong
what
like this in the spring yeah
I'm sorry sure
what do we do now
[Music]
we'll figure it out
uh what do we do now
I'm gonna figure it out
but I don't think Marlene's gonna go
wait
I like in the game the moment is ruined
by the infected one thing I have
criticized the show for is that I think
they kind of missed out on the bigger
infected moments from the game such as
the skyscraper and the hotel basement
sections this was another way they
lessened it a bit and removed the Panic
of running through them all the chase
ended with it seeming like he got out
but the scaffolding fell and Ellie
plummeted down Riley jumped back down
and this was very much a giving up her
life to save Ellie yeah she ends up
saving her as well but to me the impact
of having her jump back into the fire is
kind of lessened a bit now we did go
back and forth at the Kevin spoilers
office over why they changed it to the
one infected and our editor Matt
actually said that she wouldn't have
been as scared of The Horde in episode 5
if she'd already seen one that was the
first time this version of Ali
experienced it and therefore it wouldn't
have made sense if she'd seen one before
personally I think it's just a budget
thing and having to film a Chase through
a mall would obviously cost and you'd
have to loot more than Footlocker to get
that back should call it loot Locker not
the time I place anyway back in the
present Ali guys have been in the house
and desperately searches for something
to help Joel shout out to all my Gamers
who know what it's like hammering that
triangle button constantly as you open
up every draw for a bit just a little
bit of cloth or something now the
frustrationally has here is mirrored in
the past with her lashing out in anger
and smashing the glass like it's a
button with a thumbs up on it we get a
similar shot composition to the game and
in the end Riley makes a pack that they
just lose their minds together
okay
[Music]
there's some more stuff over there you
can break
there's more stuff over there with angry
[Music]
I see it we got two options
wait I see him we've got two options
you take the easy way out
one
it's quick and painless
I'm not a fan of option one
why don't like option
two
we fight
for what option two
we're gonna turn into one of those
things
[Music]
there are a million ways we should have
died before today
for everyone sooner or later right
and a million ways we can die before
tomorrow
but we fight
for every second we get to spend with
each other
but we don't quit it's two minutes
two days I don't want to give that up
whether it's two minutes
or two days
we don't give that up
I don't want to give that up
my vote
let's just wait it out
you know we can
be all poetic and just lose our minds
together
I could just be a boy I can [__]
what's option three
[Music]
sorry
come on
sorry I'm sorry let's get on here
[Music]
this is also a line reference in the
game by Ellie when she discusses her
past Boston
back when I Was Bitten
I wasn't alone
my best friend was there
and she got bit too
we didn't know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out
you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together
also did a bit of deep digging and the
mall in the game was apparently built in
1968 with his show of course starting
off in that year now back in the present
Ellie finds a needle and thread so that
she can stitch Joel up make sure you
sanitize that mate yeah it's been been
set in a draw for 20 years probably
probably causing infection never mind
then you go clearly Ellie is fine to
keep Joel going and this is clearly
because she lost Riley she doesn't want
to repeat of that and she very much
mirrors Joe not wanting to go through
losing his daughter again they found
each other and someone to fight for and
we end with Ali stitching up his wound
in order to stop the bleeding this shot
is framed to marry the ending of last
week's episode and whereas that was a
tower now to finish on this is a more
hopeful one that closes out the episode
and before we get into the spoiler
section of the video I thought I'd give
my thoughts as a standalone thing I did
enjoy this adaptation of the Left Behind
DLC but I don't know if I'm a bit too
close to the game as I think some parts
pailed in comparison and was just hoping
things like The Horde and the the winter
Mall sections would have been carried
across I think at this point I'm kind of
just accepting that the series will
always just strip back the game so it
mainly focuses on the human moments I do
think that leaves stuff being so
repetitive at points though and every
episode other than four and six I
believe basically introduces one or two
new characters that they then kill off
at the end so it is all good to be fair
but I think this formula almost stops it
from being great those first five
episodes especially were Classics but
the last two have kind of dropped for me
personally still good but yeah I just
feel the constraint of the series are
starting to show a bit now stormery did
a really good job as Riley and though I
probably sound like I'm bashing it I do
think that viewed in a vacuum that this
episode's really good I just think that
this show as a whole it needs a bit more
variety from the formula that we're
getting maybe I am too close to the game
like I said but it never really felt
like they were following a format or if
they were then it wasn't clear from that
initial playthrough anyway if you're
loving this show and everything that it
does then hopefully you can at least see
things from my point of view and if you
haven't played the game yet go play you
know we're lucky that we have both these
two adaptations and and there were
there's definitely going to be people
who are like well I prefer the game and
people who are like I prefer the show so
yeah everyone's gonna have their own
choice but I'm sure you can tell from me
from how much I love the game and and
all the stupid little references in it I
really do love it anyway that takes us
to the spoiler section and uh yeah we
have a couple of things that I heavily
into part two now most of the items in
Ali's room have a payoff down the line
and at one point we catch those dinosaur
drawings and also some moon cycles in
the arcade Ali also asks if the next
surprise is a dinosaur and these all tie
together for where Joe takes her on her
birthday the per Guardian Museum and
this is filled with Dinosaur exhibits as
well as the NASA one that Ali ends up
getting into being through that a number
of times so sorry we're constantly
repeating it but they also referenced it
around the campfire last week now the
AHA tape and take on me playing in the
mall returns a big moment during part
two as well a one point Ali comes across
a guitar in a music store and she picks
it up and plays it to Dina it's a great
vision and I wanted to play it in the
video but we got hit with copyright
claims so I can't but I'm gonna serenade
you with her now as we Fade Out so click
you've got to either listen to me or
click a video on the end screen talking
it away I don't know what I'm to say I
said click video anyway but that's a
nail done it's okay shine up for me come
on you would say if you'll be safe then
sorry come on take
on me take a picture
[Music]
because